while 94 one man booth at Kent here and
we've got a special guest in studio you
know we've been playing his music on
Sunday nights for a long time from the
great state of Ohio to Ohio yes we've
got Stalley stallions in the bill what's
going on what's happening okay
oh my god you're so excited yes Ohio are
you all obviously Ohio State guy yes big
time big big I might be smart that might
be your number one thing to remind be
like over the Cavs over they might be
and the only team in Ohio that's
relatively good most of the time yeah
exactly
but I mean them the Indians the Cavs
they needs went to the World Series like
20 years it was like 19 oh we got beat
by the Marlins right Frye's on the team
now so you guys are on the way anyway we
got Stanley in the building he just put
out a new project couple weeks ago right
yes called saving you said yes which is
out you could go check it out there's a
project and yo man I feel like your
album Ohio was very slept on it kind of
came and went there was I mean a song
like the record with ty dolla sign was
you should have been a smash and the
remix the remix was crazy shout out but
like I've kind of like been kind of hip
to like the way like because omarion's
are good homie and he had this song
posed to be he was obviously signed MMG
yes and posed to be was like Venice like
it was out for a very long time be fair
long before they finally were like okay
we got to push the button and make this
work yes what why do you think Ohio was
released and kind of didn't I guess get
the attention that it might have deserve
honest opinion yeah I think it was rush
you know I think that uh I thought it
was kind of rough yeah it was like oh
sure drop
as you know because like you know me and
you've known me for so long
so you know everybody was waiting for
that album and then it was kind of like
abrupt it was like hey I'm coming out
with an album by the way it's a month
from now I went so it was like it was
definitely rushed but I feel like you
know me going to jail and that situation
happen and it was like who's who's up
next who can we put out who can we go
with and I think that it was just very
unfortunate and unfair for me because I
feel like I was put in a tight situation
where it was like I wanted to be a team
player right and be like okay and plus I
wanted to give my fans that album cuz
everybody's been waiting for it and I
was even for real it was long long over
though it was like of course when I was
ready I'm like yeah let's go but you
know looking back at it it's just like
not that the album was bad or that the
album was to get yeah it was a great
album and put together sloppy or it
didn't feel rushed when you listen to it
but I just wish we took more time as far
as just the promotion of it and and
getting things in order so that should
have been as successful as it should
have been yeah so like I do feel like
with MMG like there's obviously a lot of
artists on the label there's guys you
know that sign like shout out to my dog
yattaaawan Vegas was on the lay ahead
and and you guys like yourself rocky
fresh who's finally putting out new
music again here I was like for awhile I
was like where is rocky fresh what
happened after fresh veggies yeah that's
a Jane the jewelry the building but yeah
he put out that project with Casey but
like what what in your opinion has kind
of been like the gift in the curse of
being on on MMG because obviously we all
love Ross we all love MMG and it's squad
but like you know there's certain
artists that that's it and chill and you
know you got an album out yeah you know
says so but you know man that's a good
question I really can't you know like
the gift of it is just you know I tell
people this I you know my friends are
telling y'all my friends and I tell this
you know one thing that help is it's
like it's a popularity thing it's like a
status thing
exactly it's like a status or popularity
thing but I didn't come into this game
to be popular no I didn't come into this
game for a status of a Fame I came in
because I want to be one of the greats I
want to be recognized for the music that
I put out for the the love and in the
attention and effort that I put into
each song I want to get you know that's
the love that I'm looking for or you
know that's the attention that I want
I'm gonna be known for the music first
yeah I don't I didn't come for that so
you know some people are happy with just
that some people aren't I'm one of those
people that aren't so I think that those
are my gifts in my cursus is that you
know I'm somebody who I'm as such in
love with the music with the art with
the with the art of making shirk and
with you know don't I love what I do
so it's not about you know the the fame
you know so what is the I mean saving
use of his an incredible body of work
Big KRIT on the album Gus got ray Cash
on now music I heard ray cash in a
minute Zod was fired though back there
very slept on out and clanking this
wagon shoutout ray cash man he's
definitely you know Ohio legend man I
was very very happy to have him on the
project but like what is um what is the
plan our I mean are you just doing the
the the BC the BCG thing yeah or is it
is it are you still mm gee I guess is
the question yeah um
Jase yeah yeah like I mean my focus
right now is BCG and myself you know
like I said I came here to be one of the
greats I came to put great music out and
that's what I have to do it's all love
with the MMG and Ross and you know I
appreciate course for everything he's
done for me you know he changed my life
in a lot of ways you know I mean so it's
always family and always love their
biggest backers too right yes surprising
that not a lot of people would think
people don't yeah
don't understand how much Ross had went
from I mean that he goes hard for me and
he's always you know gave nothing showed
me nothing but love and made sure people
notice to recognize the talent that I
have you know that means so for that I
you know I can't even I mean it did you
have an out about animes and he made
sure that you know and that's one thing
that he promised me and he always
delivered yeah he delivered it always
stood true to his words so like I said
it's always love but me right now what I
have to focus on is me back to that
intelligent trunk music boy exactly I
got to get back to that intelligent
trunk music and why I came in here for I
mean what I came for
and um you know I want people to
understand that and to know that you
know sometimes when you like are up
under that thumb or you you kind of like
behind the man or next to the man that's
not right the man like sometimes you got
to be like hold up let me let me push my
way to the front and let me really sign
now and I it's just time to show uh
you're obviously a conscious guy yeah
anybody who listens to your music would
know that about you what do you think
about all of this outrage from this
Beyonce halftime I was looking at it I
think I was walking into the hotel and
it was all like seeing this like I'm day
why are you seeing and talking about
like it's been weeks
boy cotton and the strange like you know
I said it I think a couple maybe a week
or two ago I did an interview I forget
who but I was just basically saying like
I'm so proud of Beyonce for what she did
at the Super Bowl on that stage and
Beyonce being who she is we need more
people like beyond straight up to really
step up and to make our presence known
and more our presence felt and I don't
think she did it in a classless way I
don't think she did it in a forceful way
I think she did it very very very very
complain during the baryon say do you
know what I'm saying like she did it in
a way that was very it just was good you
know it was a good look and like I said
it wasn't real boisterous it wasn't loud
it wasn't in your face it was just real
subtle and it still made it
as you can see they're still talking
about it saying what Kendra Kendra I
mean I'm so proud of the kids you know
it was one of the illest I just wish you
would I wish you would've got that album
of the year man man so and he you know
he deserved it you know shoutout
Kendricks shoutout Beyonce for really
being a voice being more than a voice
you know really taking action and
showing the world
hey we here and we gonna be heard and
we're gonna be respected let me ask you
this cuz I tweeted this the other day
and I truly I mean obviously I'm from
the West Coast I've been a fan of
Kendrick since he was Kate out back in
the day yeah but I said on on Twitter I
said if biggie is top 10 all-time off
two albums Kendrick stopped in all time
right now cuz he got two albums out do
you mean am I crazy no he's on his way
yeah he's definitely close like I mean
what he's done the impact that he's had
and the to like this guy is literally
like we all love nas nas my favorite
emcee of all time but like he is like
what nas like nas obviously Illmatic was
incredible it was written was incredible
but but like nas didn't like have granny
moments like that like he is like
performance mama control like he is like
what we all want nods to be exact we all
want what we wanted as a kid we right
nas to be that times of chance to engine
and a hip hop is much bigger than
especially that type of hip hop the type
of hit I mean I don't want to say that
site Bret just the music no it is
interesting because in in the grass in
the landscape of rap right now it's
really like I mean obviously I love
Drake Drake makes good music but like
Drake you'll never hear a record of
Drake's actually talking about anything
really
he makes great records about these
strippers he who the chick she's bang he
makes club what was that me you and the
six or so yeah I mean drink and rap his
ass off right then you know it's like
future and then a whole bunch of people
trying to sound like future the fact
like Kendrick is existing in selling
records and being successful in this
climate
crazy it's amazing yeah exactly with the
spinning spinning station yeah that was
a great show man shout-out Phoenix man
they energy was insane in there but yeah
Kendrick you know I got to be on the
road with Kendrick and that was I
believe his first major tour like that
was like 30 dates and 35 days and that
was definitely mine too and he actually
brought me out there with him so I
always forever you know will love him
for that because that was a moment that
you know in this time that um you know
I'll always cherish you know I'm saying
my first major tour with Kendrick right
before a good kid maad city drop let's
go we got to build it was me him so us
absolutely right you know I'm saying so
you know shoutout topping all them they
show love and um you know I'm just so
and it's so crazy to see how fast he
took goes quicker that like it was
really because literally the tour was
over and they're like two weeks later
his album came out and then he was with
I remember he was back like he came back
and get like yeah it's crazy like so
yeah it was very fast now shout out
kendrick man i'm proud of what he's
doing because you know he's doing what
what i want to do and what I'm what I'm
striving to do as well so he's just
opening that door and set in that stage
for artists like myself to be able to
come right behind him pause and be
successful and that's really just being
you and that's the thing that I take
from him J Cole guys like that I know
they're all those two guys are kind of
always mentioned when you talk about
those guys and you know he deserves some
Grammys too you know but you know just
those guys being themselves making the
music that they want to make it and
stand true is definitely refreshing you
know and like these days of the futures
and the Drake's not knocking them but
just course you know that's where we at
with it so to see them doing and to be
excelling at what they do in this state
of hip-hop or rap music whatever we call
whatever we call that that Psalm is a
beautiful thing who
some of the new guys that you're
listening to um kind of give you that
same feeling who have I listened to that
I could say chance you know chance is
definitely you know a dope dual man you
know it's funny I really don't listen to
hip-hop because unfortunately I don't
get inspired by hip-hop you know I mean
I don't think anybody's really pushing
the bar outside of the guys that we just
mentioned right I know what I'm saying I
think everybody's really just following
suit or doing the same thing so I kind
of tap into other music and uh you know
where I get my inspiration because I
feel like they're really pushing the bar
as far as creating like what are you
talking like I listen to a band called
like Japanese house off the top of my
head I like I like blood orange what
else do i listed so I like Kurt Vile
John Mayer drummers that's the only
person you know but these are like
artists who who play instruments who
also write their own music like
literally like write music and write
lyrics you know so I'm inspired by that
type of thing you know and um good
songwriting who can paint pictures and
tell stories like that's where hip-hop
used to be I feel and I feel like that's
where they're at you know even somebody
like Sam hunt you know who's like a
commando like he paints a picture though
he you know he's very um you know
articulate I guess I don't know but he
definitely paints a picture he's
definitely has great lyrics and he's a
great storyteller so I tried to listen
to that and then I go into older hip-hop
when I listen to hip-hop hey why do you
think it's so crazy because I just
watched I don't know if you're familiar
with triumph the insult comic dog the
puppet though he had like a election
special on Hulu that's like the funny if
you you're bored on the airplane okay
just be marking Ted Cruz and Donald
Trump as' is hilarious okay but I'm just
curious why do you think it is like that
in 2016 like the two top Republican
dudes are the most batshit crazy racist
just absolutely
is it what we like but you know it's
kind of like hip-hop it's it's
entertainment
we like the person who's losing their
mind and giving the cycle is having a
you know a mental breakdown in front of
us and it gives us something to talk
about to meme about to you know all
those things and it's crazy it is crazy
and it's like is that America yeah you
know it's crazy I feel like it's just
really like yo finally there's a
candidate that says something that all
these racist white people are that are
just thinking in their head but they
don't ever want to say it but now
there's someone saying exactly
he's we behind them and that's why I
said is that America because it's a part
of it for sure and it's gotten out of
hand like it's the fourth they even have
gotten this far it's crazy and it's
really is it all stems from the fact
that African American president was
alone at with but let's be crazy
and which but what's crazy is like he is
like low-key like middle of the road
with a lot of [__] like he's like had to
compromise so much like you can't even
say nothing about to do like that's true
but are you voting like are you do you
have your candidate you I don't have my
feeling the Bern he's seeming like the
one but you see his interview with
killer Mike yeah good good but must be
kind of cool to have Larry David in the
office yeah but you know it's just crazy
because it's like I don't know man on
both sides I'm kind of like it's like
goddamn bring somebody else out the back
right but I mean I I feel like we all
have to vote like it's important this
year is important just I mean as all the
years have been it's very important
because we can't let it get out of
control now you used to play you played
basketball against LeBron before right
he high school high school so I have to
ask you you're a Cavaliers fan yes this
guy's
weird LeBron James Jersey he played his
ass off in the final yes that's great
Wow that's why not cuz she won but
that's why I go so hard for LeBron
because it's not about even if he was
really leading it's about yeah it's like
he's he's the epitome of Ohio and he's a
great representation of our state
he always conducts himself well-mannered
he's a family man he hasn't done
anything embarrassing for the cultures
never for the import but you know I'm
saying this like and and he was he's
just special on the court you know I
mean you know so I'm just proud of that
you know what I'm saying I don't want to
be like this crazy LeBron like fan or
you know whatever but I'm just proud of
that somebody from from home and so
close it's doing such a great job on a
worldwide scale and he's definitely
doing it graceful for sure now like
Cleveland specifically there's your cell
well you're not specifically from clear
but right outside cleanest 45 minutes
yeah so there's like obviously bomb pose
and harmony you got the gods of the
region or yes
Kid Cudi yes chip yourself MGK yes do
you have what's your relationship like
with a guy like MGK for example oh it's
love every time we see each other you
know is is
you're the one you stayed out of it yeah
in the record you're the one who's
everything chillin everything is good
now those beef I don't know too much
about it but Kid Cudi MGK in kingship
MGK how the story I don't know if they
even know MGK is on tour and Kid Cudi of
the show House of Blues he brought both
of them MGK and oh no don't cut he has
grown up a bit was it was unnecessary
man was too there's not many
yeah and that's like I don't have a
problem I don't know Cuddy like well you
know me that's one of the guys that I
don't know I've met chip a few times
we've had conversations don't have we do
actually in chip a few out here looking
listening where I don't know what the
camera put that song out made it out
okay that's all like three years ago
chip is the homie we got a record
together that he has he's been whole
North to it but as far like I'm cool
with him MGK I don't know Cuddy enough
or I don't even know the last I probably
met him years ago so I really not for
too familiar interaction was on any of
the members of own I'm I have a I had a
little bit of interaction but they ain't
no it's all love with them you know I
mean I mean they don't oh jeez they
divorce you know they the pioneers of it
man I like they one of the reasons why I
ever started rapping for real radar
they're very like in the in the grand
scheme of looking back and people
talking about some of the greatest like
I feel like they know they own the great
one like own they don't get they don't
get they don't get to just do me a
change like when I was a kid they were
like the big like like in Arizona that's
their bit funny Phoenix Arizona ROM from
originally is their biggest selling
market of all time they come there three
times a year and sell out but like when
I was a kid Bowen was like it was like
bone and Tupac they were everything like
to me like I think I grew afro I have
braised everything like just because
Bizzy Bone is like a such a slim busy
can shop bro but ya know like that's
bring out his [__] mind for the
record he's amazing I mean but to answer
your question like as far as Ohio
rappers go
um especially in the Cleveland I mean
this all love I don't know if they got
problems with me but you know as me not
so saving you Civ is out what is what is
this kind of like warm up it feels like
just kind of like hey guys um you know
yeah this is the one we're here yeah
this is really the I'm still here take
this enjoy it and we have a lot more on
the way like this is really just like I
have so much story for this year man I'm
so how many records you signed on like a
lot I mean everybody called me the
hoarder
you're a hoarder also looks like I know
I'm like yeah I have a lot of music but
this year I'm putting them like a lot of
songs that was all saving use of were uh
you know three four years old Wow yeah
yeah yeah like like oh like cut a rug
was three years old him but I yeah but
crit on it but yeah there's a lot of
song you know what it makes sense cuz
STS is on it he was on it three or four
years like well I haven't seen that
guy's name it right yeah yeah a lot of
those songs were like old records so
like I'm starting to do some spring
cleaning
you don't mean and then get ready for
the next album but I'm excited you just
like stay in the studio is that like
you're just saying man I'm like a few
asses off you have a good studio at the
crib yeah like oh well I write a lot at
the crib and then I go into the studio
but I'm either way just depends on the
move I sometimes I want that good studio
atmosphere sometimes I'll just do
everything in the house but as far as
you know like working I'm always working
that's why I know a lot of my fans they
don't see me post on Twitter or
Instagram a lot or I mean I seen you but
I'm working but you know and they they
start to realize now because now people
be like I'll put something out and
they'll he was working he was too quiet
or something like like like I'm assuming
you're sitting on some pretty fire beats
I feel like I want to hear you want some
9th wonder I think that would be the lit
I think that might have to happen that
might have any nice is doing this thing
with Jam la records and grab cities I
you got to do a record with Rap City -
yeah shout-out right he's fire yeah I
was in a Carolina at knife studio
maybe two years they'll catch a lecture
she fell asleep on the couch but it was
late though it was after one of the
shows but now I definitely got to get up
with a knife on me
he's somebody who supported me when
Lincoln Way Knights came out he was a
real he was very vocal about that
project and how he appreciated so I
would love to get in with ninth there's
a couple people you know Shafiq I've
heard the name but he stays like
one-third of the Sirah okay okay yeah
he's out so you know we've been talking
about doing some stuff yeah it's gonna
be like I said got some stuff I've
definitely got some oh you know that's
my dress that's all from that day mirror
because even with crit it was like your
favorite memories of that cuz that
collective was that's my high school ya
know that is one of the way you're a
goddamn baby yeah but not like those
were some of the best years for me being
a artist and really starting to like
hone in on my craft to be I was blessed
put it like that to be in the room like
there was times when I was in the room
like this and I would look around and
it's like currency here Jay Electronica
hair most def hair ski beats hair the
way is right there the black what was
the album's that Dame put out the Black
Rock oh my god yes no like damn all
Burke he's of the Black Keys you know
they from Akron Ohio
it's so great William Firestone High
School and the Black Keys are so popular
now they're yeah they're you're the
Black Rock Album I think there was two
of them but the first one now was crazy
with sin souls
I mean Nicole Rae was on there it's a
MOS on there mostly yeah that's some
cool kids like but that's one saying
there was times when you were in the
room or there was times when we have
open mics or whatever Erykah Badu would
be on the mic they're mostly good on the
mic then I get on the mic the currency
then you know the cool kid it was just
crazy like print was there there's a
I'm curious cuz you said when you're
working at a life when you moved from
Massillon to New York have you had one
CD you gave it to moe yeah when's the
next time you saw him like in the
situation he go oh it's you yeah you
know the next time I seen he was
probably it might it was either months
or like maybe a year later we bumped
into each other again and it was in heat
you know it was still love you remember
me or whatever and then and then after
that and then we did you know shoulder
it was like some shows and stuff and
then I was like just on the road and
then whoa
and then we bumped into each other again
at DeeDee 172 well at the dojo that was
the next time so I gave him the CD
bumped into him like a little bit later
after that and then the next time bumped
into him again at DeeDee 170 soon when
he seemed he was like you like you know
you know and it was always love and he's
one of the big reasons why I continued
to do music because I gave him that CD
he gave me those encouraging words of
like yo you got it keep doing it like
stay yourself like it was just like one
of those moments where it was like it
was like kind of like a paramedic moment
where it was like okay I'm doing the
right thing like because most def
somebody that I looked at in the mind as
a child you know like and kind of grew
up listening to well did grow up listen
he is one of the people who was like yo
you got some you doing it you catch a
lot of people shop lives in a day life
or did you not actually nobody day we
you know we was a second pretty minimal
like Boutique right yeah he wasn't gonna
try yeah and we had some scary people in
them yo that's what's up man we'll look
the project's out right now yeah I'm
gonna let you introduce any song I have
the whole whole mixtape clean thank
thank you for that by the way these
rappers out here I Bob I just have him
clean up all the songs usually but yeah
well I had to get it to you um
what song should we get into let's get
into well I've no cut of rug into my
girls pants featuring crit off saving
Yusef out
now check out the sound cloud of Sal
cloud calm backslash more music coming
more music is coming a lot more music a
lot more yeah soon catch me venison
alley man yeah